Frances Fitzgerald when you look into
the book they're actually the two
volumes that reporting Vietnam and find
your peace the long fear written back in
1966 does it still work it seems a long
time ago I tell you good but I I must
leave that for others to judge whether
it works or not I know it's um I spent a
good deal of time in Vietnam and that
was one of the first things that I wrote
when I got there what does it say well
it's about a trip through the Delta in
fact it's rather like one of Peters
pieces and later on and we used to go on
these travels to try and figure out what
was going on going on and so this is a
piece about people I met along the way
you know from Arvin generals to American
advisers to wow how dignitaries the
local religious sect that in the Delta
and just a piece of reportage it's very
simple I I didn't know very much about
the Vietnam at that time I just got
there and so it was attempt to sort of
look at something Peter can you happen
to have in the second volume part to the
first piece and it's also from the
Mekong Delta but it's a couple years
later in nineteen sixty-nine when you go
back and read it what comes to mind well
I think probably the same point that
Frankie was making but I think one thing
we might have shared as reporters
covering Vietnam was at least the effort
to get out in the countryside and try to
see the the war in kind of microcosm to
actually talk as best one could to
farmers into arvin sergeants and to
American advisers and and to try to
describe what we saw in this particular
case I think the point I was making if
there was a larger point was that
actually about a year after the
the Tet Offensive which was see no such
a disaster and in some senses was for
the American cause of the Mekong Delta
was surprisingly peaceful and I think
the point I made is yeah one could spend
a week going through the Delta on buses
and Sam pads and so on without being
shot at and I thought that perhaps said
something about the way the war was
going at that particular time in that
particular place how long were you in
Vietnam I lived there some straight time
for a couple of years so 67 through 69
and then between 70 and 75 I probably
spent a third to a half of each of those
years back in Vietnam but based in Hong
Kong Frances Fitzgerald how long were
you there for about a year in 1966 and
then I went home and I wrote my book and
I went back again in 1971 for about six
months and i was out there again in 73
of about three months in 74 I went to
Hanoi and I've been back three or four
years ago pictured on the screen is a
view from the book and what do you both
think of this two-volume set their 1500
pages 64 pages of photographs some 80
writers some 113 pieces I think they've
done a magnificent job I really do I
think it's very difficult it's one of
the most difficult things I think the
Library of America is undertaken good
because the sheer volume of reportage
and of course there's things left out
that one hates to leave out I would have
hated to do the job of editing this but
I think that they've managed to give
both a sort of chronological picture of
the war and also to really judge things
more or less by literary merit value
they try and do both at once is
necessarily making compromises but I
think they've done a great job York on
your pictures in here also you remember
where this picture was taken get it on
the screen just a second there it is
yeah it's kind of embarrassing everyone
else's in military fatigues and I'm on a
beach carrying a watermelon I think it
was on some island off the southern
coast of Vietnam maybe phu quoc island
something like that what do you think of
this two-volume set if you read it do
you get a good sense of what that war
was all about yeah i think the volumes
in total give a pretty good sense not a
clear sense because i think even all
these years later it's very hard to be
totally clear about what vietnam was all
about much less how it turned out and
why but i think a little like you know
blind people touching parts of an
elephant no reporter saw the whole story
or understood the whole story but this
collection has so many stories by so
many by and large terrific journalists
then I think someone who actually goes
through it does collectively get a sense
of what Vietnam was all about I'm
looking at a piece that's dated October
1966 it's actually written by the man
who ten years ago was our first guest on
book notes this is the 500th book notes
and we went back to Vietnam on purpose
because it's been kind of a thread in
the program he wrote in 1966 Neil
Sheehan there were many disappointments
those first two years but when I left
Vietnam in 1964 I was still to use the
current parlance a hawk i returned to
Saigon in 1965 for another year now i
have left again and much has changed
there were seventeen thousand american
servicemen in vietnam at the time of my
first departure there are now three
hundred and seventeen thousand and I
while not a dove am no longer a hawk put
Neil Sheehan in context if you would and
what about what he's saying right here
well again Neil is one of those
reporters who went
back and back over the years and um
that's an important point I did Peter
was making as well it is that that uh
you know the war was not one thing at
one time it had no dramatic unities of
the way ways some do that that if you if
you went in any given year you would you
would see something quite different and
your impression would probably be formed
by that but Neil who had long experience
was one of the few people who were able
to make a statement like that i mean i
think that the others of us would have
would have been shy about doing so at
least but he had had seen so much that I
think he had the authority to say okay
this is this is way I feel about writing
in The New York Times Magazine do you
think that was a good thing for a
reporter to do oh I think magazine
journalism is still journalism and in
fact some of the best pieces in that
book we're magazine pieces jimster buzz
piece about the grunts which I think
came closer than anything else to
capturing the life and attitudes of the
GI let me read what I was really trying
to be at that point is asking about
whether it was a good idea for a
reporter to take a point of view at that
time okay the what my perspective on
that would actually be that most
reporters in Vietnam were not Hawks or
doves in the sense that the American
public lined up a little like I don't
think most reporters are right-wing or
left-wing in a current political context
I I think most reporters who covered
Vietnam for any length of time became
critics some more some less but all to
some extent became critics of the way
the war was being waged we weren't in a
position to be critics of what the
Communists were doing because we
couldn't follow their troops around and
we couldn't see the destruction they
were causing and we could
see the that the suffering that they
caused but we certainly could see that
which our own troops and our allies
caused so in one way or another we all
became critics but I don't think we were
by and large ideologues on the war I
don't think we started or even ended in
most cases with the proposition that one
side was evil and one side was good and
I'm not sure most of us even really
concluded that America shouldn't have
tried to wage that war I didn't at least
I think what we did conclude is we wound
up waging it badly I agree with Peter
more or less I think the part of it was
generational too i mean the the first
reporters who went there in the you know
1959 so on attended to come from world
war two and to have certain assumptions
about what happens or what reporters
ought to do when America goes to war and
those assumptions were really broken by
Neil Sheehan and David Halberstam mal
Brown and so on they've they found that
they had to become critics because they
were lied to a lot of the time bye bye
bye Americans there on the ground and
they became very unpopular with the
embassy and with with the military
command and so forth and there was the
sort of antagonism between reporters and
the sort of higher officials you know
all throughout the war because I mean
they were essentially trying to say
we're we're doing fine we're winning
them but there's nothing going wrong at
all and therefore you you know you've
found that you had to examine those
every single statement that was made
practically to see whether it was really
the case or not it made reporting very
difficult I tell you it kept having to
go to the Delta to find out whether what
they were saying about it was 0 or not
and so this I think this this antagonism
created a perhaps more of its more of a
sense that you know that reporters were
on one side or in other words I don't
think they really where they're just
trying to trying to do their job and the
antagonism I Mesa it did not extend to
two GIS or or to anybody who was you
know on those sort of lower levels it
was a really high level policy Joe Kraft
columnist who's not a no longer live as
a piece in this from July of 1972's in
The New Yorker and he actually went to
Hanoi and he has in here the actual
words from Ho Chi Minh's which he may
have died in nineteen sixty-nine Ho Chi
Minh's will that he passed on to people
who would still alive as a matter of
fact generals app is still alive it's
probably the most successful general in
the world I guess according to some
people at a passage reads like this the
war of resistance is Ho Chi Minh the war
of resistance against us aggression may
drag on our people may have to face new
sacrifices of life and property whatever
happens we must keep firm are resolved
to fight the US aggressors till total
victory he says no matter what
difficulties and hardships lie ahead our
people are sure of total victory the US
imperialists will certainly have to quit
our fatherland will certainly be
reunified our fellow countrymen in the
south and the north will certainly be
reunified under the same roof we a small
nation will have earned this the signal
honor of defeating through heroic
struggle to big imperialism's the French
and the American and of making a worthy
contribution to the world national
liberation movement was he accurate then
and is he anchored today well he turned
out to be accurate in his prediction and
I think probably no American who covered
Vietnam understood what motivated the
North Vietnamese as well as Frankie who
wrote a kind of definitive book on that
fire and the light but I don't
personally think there was an
inevitability about that
direction I think the war could have
turned out differently but it would have
taken a lot more sacrifice and it is
certainly arguable that it wasn't worth
the additional sacrifice to continue the
war for another decade let's say or to
inflict the kind of punishment on North
Vietnam that might have actually caused
them to have to stop the particularly
the the main force troop movements of
the 70s were you ever at going could I
take another tack on that Peter is
extremely kind to call firing like
definitive but it hardly is so it's it's
not it's it was you know just a grope in
the beginning I mean what is so
surprising about this war has compared
to others past I mean any other war that
the US has fought was how little we
understood the other site or knew
anything about them how little effort we
made to see whether in fact it was
possible to achieve at least some of our
objectives without fighting the war and
I think that only now are we beginning
to get some understanding of the kinds
of debate that went on in Hanoi the cut
the problems that they were having with
their with Soviet Union and with China
which prevented them from actually
moving towards any negotiation with us
we're seeing the kinds of struggles that
went on within the Politburo between ho
chi minh and lays lon for example be
different policies 10 chi minh dodd you
know or even before his death the policy
become much harder so to me that's the
that's the big unknown of the war and
really this this volume and i think does
it doesn't get to that there are a few
pieces from hanoi but it still was so
much of an unknown and it says very
strange thing to fight a war with with
the a total
on the other side look over on the
screen if you would i'm going to show
you some of the photographs from this
book and just either one of you just
comment on any of that's Malcolm Brown
1963 what role did he play mal Browns
just a great reporter what yeah before
before my time one of the icons George
asper usually any penalty ap George was
a tea and George SAT for years and years
and years in in the AP office and wrote
the daily war story for AP he went to
the to the briefings he listened to the
often usually inflated figures from the
military briefers he tried to put it
into some kind of context with reports
coming in from 80 people in the field
any day after day wrote that daily war
story that was probably the mainstay of
most newspapers throughout the war on
the right here in this photograph is
Peter Arnett on the left is Horst Foust
horse past the photographer right role
did you know them over there uh yeah
sure they were there forever too I think
Horace foz probably logged more years
than anybody but I may be wrong about
that it took as many risks as any well
as anyone tended to be the case with the
photographers who had to put their heads
up when there was fighting going on as
opposed to the rest of us who could duck
Lori Emerson here is the scene within a
soldier of the American Americal
division she has a number of pieces in
here glorieux is a great pal and she was
there in the 69 70 71 period she covered
lamb some 719 I remember which was the
the Vietnamese incursion into Laos
and she did some of the great reporting
of the world I it turns out that there's
a piece I don't think it's in there but
it's it I think of all pieces that
annoyed the the military brass hers was
it she discovered that some general I
forget who it was was faking his own
medals citations and so on and she had
to she got the people who wrote the
citations for the general the GIS and it
to a military man that's the worst thing
that could can happen I think you both
have something in common with this man
James P sterba you're on the rise my
husband where did you mean and my
colleague hey he's still with the wall
street journal yes he was writing for
The New York Times at that time and in
Vietnam how long have you two been
married um since 1990 so we we only met
subsequently it back here in New York
and what kind of a reporter is he she
jim was was really one of the great
combat reporters but in the best sense
of that I don't mean just the bangbang I
mean Jim spent an awful lot of his time
out in the field with the GIS and the
rifle companies not in the battalion
headquarters not in the regimental
headquarters in the division you know
compounds as soon as I mentioned earlier
i'm in the gyms piece on the i think
it's called the grunts in that book was
one of the kind of seminal pieces of
reporting of the war i think this man
died just a short time ago when he died
he was at the library of congress Peter
brace trip who wrote for The Washington
Post and also had a couple volumes on
the media and Vietnam what was his take
in the end um well I appears quite
conservative a general and does he sound
and politically conservative I think so
yes I mean would say that and he's also
a really good reporter 2 and um I didn't
know I'm really they're very well I
don't
what do you think I knew Peter well and
admired him Peter's probably main
contribution beyond good reportage was a
book called Tet I think it's two volumes
and it really does try to dissect the
Tet Offensive and get beyond I think the
somewhat stereotypical idea that this
was a total disaster for the South
Vietnamese and the Americans and looks
at it from a more historical perspective
and says that the Vietcong in the North
Vietnamese suffered enormous casualties
that in a military sense it really was
much more of a defeat for the Communists
even though politically it wound up
being a great success for them and I
think there was some evidence to support
that and in Vietnam in the several years
after the Tet Offensive really had the
America and the South Vietnamese Army on
the offensive and the North Vietnamese
in the Vietcong quite desperately trying
to rebuild their forces then of course
we started leaving Vietnam and we left
our allies somewhat alone with our
tactics but without our support and
eventually they lost but it Peter made
quite a contribution with that book I
think let me ask both of you about your
own lives where did you grow up in New
York City parents well one of the
reasons I went to Vietnam in first place
is that I had a father who spent the
world war two in China and then worked
for the CIA and Desmond Fitzgerald and
he spent some time in Vietnam as well as
other places and I mean I when I first
went out there was sort of quite casual
in a way it was just too I thought I
would do a couple of pieces and come
back oh I mean practically you know I
want to see Asia
and I was writing for freelance for
magazines and so forth but I what I
wanted to see where he'd been I wanted
to see that part of his life your mom my
mother they were divorced at this this
todd mom they were divorced just after
world war two actually uh and she became
one of the ambassador's he got to the
united nations mary had a tree marietta
tree uh why did you get into writing and
are you still writing I'm still writing
what kind of writing do you do today
well I've been working for a very long
time on a book that I just about to
finish on Reagan and star wars and the
end of the Cold War Peter gone how did
you get into this business I think ever
since I was a little kid I've fell in
love with newspapers I published one on
her in our neighborhood when I was nine
years old and made my mother type it on
an old typewriter for me and sold it for
three cents a copy and and ever since I
love newspapers so where was the
neighborhood princeton new jersey and
what took me to vietnam i guess like a
lot of people was that's where the
action was i mean if if you were a
journalist in the mid-60s and you've had
the opportunity to get there it clearly
was the great story and I think to some
extent probably still would rank as the
great journalistic story of our
generation did you ever think when you
were in Vietnam or riding for a living
that you'd end up running dow jones and
running the wall street journal no was
that a goal of yours not at all when did
it start to become clear to you that you
were going to switch over to management
and have that kind of a future I think
these transitions kind of happen in
stages and I'm not sure there's a
particular point it when the war ended
in Vietnam unlike a lot of the
journalists who went home I stayed on in
Asia
and we actually started an Asian edition
of The Wall Street Journal they the
Asian Wall Street Journal which was a
bit of a gamble because it assumed Asia
was going to turn out well that Domino's
were not in fact going to fall and they
didn't of course so at that point I
became a kind of editor and publisher of
a small newspaper and somehow that later
on led the coming back here and doing it
on a larger scale one of the things this
book shows in the back as a chronology
of the war goes all the way back to the
40s and then it indicates through from
1960 all the way up through 1973 how
many Americans were in Vietnam every
year and how many died every year and
the chart just a curb and it starts to
the first year that shows des is 1964
260 there were twenty-three thousand
three hundred Americans there and the
last year chose death is 1973 the last
troops are out by 29 March of 1973 and
the year that the most troops were there
is 1968 with her five hundred thirty six
thousand and the number of deaths that
year were 14,500 in your opinion how did
we get in there and then how did we get
out essentially this but the same way
that is to say we got in there without
ever the US government sort of making a
coherent decision of what they were
going to do what their policy was going
to be it was essentially always a
holding action and getting out it was
holding action as well it was it was
about not losing as opposed to winning
nobody knew what winning what might mean
because for a simple fact that is that
that the Saigon government was never a
successful political entity if it had
been the war would have been totally
different as it was it was simply a sort
of an administration rah and an army as
opposed to a real government so
what stagger me was reading the Pentagon
Papers where I discovered that in 1961
McNamara thought that it would require a
quarter of a million troops to keep not
losing and that was such a good guess I
mean in fact they were to double that
number but it I had no idea at the time
when I was reporting therein 66 that the
estimates were really so pessimistic
internally I think that there were a lot
of people really understood this quite
well it turned out my father did I
didn't know that he didn't tell me he
doesn't he never said anything that his
business to me but the CIA estimates
were always quite very pessimistic so I
got in incrementally I think really for
largely for political reasons so I mean
in the sense that if you know it's not
going to work out well you got you've
got a real decision to make and they got
out just you know hoping that the Saigon
government could keep on going until
what there was a so-called decent
interval and that's what they achieved
the first piece in here in 1959 from
Time magazine first us advisers killed
in south vietnam it reads doesn't say
who actually wrote it because in those
days they weren't telling it was right
in those timepieces and the first murder
is hail of bullets Ovan and it's ovn A&D
and major buis fell and died within
minutes captain Howard Boston of blade
blares Berg Iowa was seriously wounded
and two Vietnamese guards were killed
that was 59 last out in 73 how do we get
in there and have to get out oh I think
we got in fundamentally and of course
incremental II believing that we were
resisting
a somewhat more monolithic communism
that actually existed as most of what
Frankie just said I would agree with I I
do think though that the none of us
probably ever gave quite enough credit
to if not the government of South
Vietnam the army of South Vietnam I mean
America losts fifty thousand lives there
the South Vietnamese Army lost five or
six times that many lives and fought for
25 years some of it with an awful lot of
Americans support some of it without
much American support and at the end the
South Vietnamese Army actually behaved
very well in in some of the the next two
final battles the penultimate battles
the final ones were retreat and route
but a you know we have a tendency to
kind of look at our own sacrifices and
casualties and to look at the enormous
suffering that the North Vietnamese were
willing to withstand to win that war
what tends to get forgotten are the
South Vietnamese allies who actually
trusted us and in many cases fought very
well in a lot of little mud-walled
outposts all over the delta and and
elsewhere in the country and those of
course are they in some cases the
Vietnamese who have made it to this
country after the reeducation camps and
the as boat people or otherwise and who
are now raising their kids here and
sending them to MIT so I I think they
deserve a little more attention and they
get from almost any of the reporting in
this in these books if you look at the
two backgrounds of the two of you here
and tell me if I'm right you're on the
board of the advisory board of the
Nation magazine mm-hmm and you run the
wall street journal I think most people
would say those two publications aren't
on the same side on a lot of issues you
sound today when you talk about Vietnam
not angry with each other not angry
about this issue not on different sides
you all know that it wasn't
way back in those days what happened
here well I'm sure we have disagreements
but the there is you know anyone who
lived through that war has that so much
more in common with each other than they
do with people who didn't and I includes
GIS there that you know it's sort of it
in this experience was so important to
both of our lives and we actually got
arrested ones together we're tell fated
well we i we for reasons I can't
remember anymore we were very anxious to
get into some American military base
near near trong somewhere that was the
big one it was a big base yeah it was
the it was it was the purpose and I
guess we wandered into some restricted
area of the base and we got arrested by
the empties and tossed into a not all
that uncomfortable kind of holding pen
and the only frustration was we we
wanted to get on with our reporting day
and we wound up spending the day and
most of the evening locked in this room
but eventually we got out but anyway we
so we are we are friends but I you know
I don't think again that either of us as
reporters approached the war primarily
ideologically if we might disagree on
anything it might be with the benefit of
all this hindsight now the two decades
later what to make of the war I i would
take these days somewhat the position
that Vietnam was a battle we lost in a
larger war that way one which is to say
the Cold War or the war for the future
of Asia and that if you look at Asia
today leave aside a current economic or
financial crisis but fundamentally Asia
turned out very well
I minute the Domino's so-called Domino's
held Asia is essentially comprised now
of free if not totally free for your
societies and largely free markets and I
think one can argue that the ten years
America spent in Vietnam actually wound
up buying time for Asia to achieve a
level of stability and prosperity that
lasts today and then in a larger sense
you know Vietnam was one of many battles
we fought in a in a very long cold war
so it you know maybe there we'd have a
somewhat different perspective but I
don't think we would have had a very
different perspective on what was going
on on the ground in Vietnam there's some
other photos in here I wanted had
reported on ask you about here's a
rather young michael kinsley who was at
Harvard I think during that time the
peace in hears from the Harvard Crimson
and Peter Connie used to be attached to
the Harvard Crimson a lot of Harvard a
lot of Harvard graduates among these
reporters did you notice that when you
were there oh hey I don't think it was
he talked to the Princeton graduate I
don't think it was one of it didn't
really occur to me at the time I think
there were a lot of young reporters I
think that would probably have more been
the the common thread I didn't know
Kingsley there and I I don't actually
know him now so I can't help on that one
here's a group Robert Chaplin kies beach
George MacArthur bud Marik kies beach
being right here he's no longer alive
but in this piece he was with the
Chicago Daily News I want to just quote
what he said and a piece that was
written May first nineteen seventy five
then the door closed this was the last
day when they as they were leaving he
tells about leaving the roof of the
embassy on 75 in April then the door
closed closed on the most humiliating
chapter in American history degree
I don't know his humiliation is not the
way I saw it I mean I just thought as a
as a criminal waste and I I was angry a
good deal of the time because it seemed
to me that you know I mean we were
destroying ourselves just and destroying
the Vietnamese and in fact that you know
the casualties in Indochina as a whole
were were just so enormous and it seemed
to me that none of this was necessary I
think we could have come up with what
what Peter suggested the outcome was
without going to war at all I just think
what where we failed was politically and
diplomatically early on and we were
driven by I think really internal
domestic demands sort of put 44 you know
don't lose China don't lose Vietnam sort
of thing and we just never even
considered the possibilities of a
neutral South Vietnam well I I think it
is you know it's very hard to debate
what might have been I I think Frankie
is right that there were opportunities
very early on to avoid going to war in
Vietnam at all I think however it we did
wind up getting into that war for
largely good motives we wound up
fighting the war in a very destructive
and ultimately self-destructive way and
the point I was making before is simply
that if one now looks back with
hindsight I do think that those who at
least Americans who sacrificed their can
feel that something good came of it that
Asia did turn out well and that I think
is not incidental might it have turned
out well anyway possibly so but it has
turned out very well
so I would say that America's sacrifice
in Vietnam but ought to get some degree
of the credit for that hey there are
asians like Lee Kuan Yew who would who
would very much agree with that former
premier of Singapore this man has a
piece in here John as McCain the third
he wrote a piece for US News and World
Report talking about what it was like to
be a plw and he's a potential
presidential candidate in the next
couple years I this is kind of a
political question of Frances Fitzgerald
what if someone ran on the strength of
being a poww or a war hero in Vietnam in
the year 2000 what impact do you think
would have on a campaign well you know
John McCain was also partly responsible
for the fact that we now have an embassy
in Hanoi I mean he's been one of the
people who really quite heroically
because he had a terrible experience and
many years in poww camps but he has been
working for a reconciliation and he was
was a one of the people who stood up and
certainly the primary one on the
Republican side who stood up and
insisted that that we resume diplomatic
relations was the wall street journal
forest resuming diplomatic relations
with Vietnam yeah the wall street
journal beliefs and diplomatic relations
and it actually believes in trade
relations also in this book pictures
like this of Sydney schanberg a movie
was made of killing fields about his
life and Cambodian any comment on him
New York Times reporters still here in
the New York area it was a really
remarkable a piece of reporting on on
the invasion of phnom penh by the Khmer
Rouge I I think I wrote about it at the
time and in the some kind of media
journal saying that you know the two
great pieces of literature were before
and after the war when one was graham
greene's a great novel The Quiet America
and I thought that Sydney's was the
other piece as we came it I think it's
accurate to say that the press corps
suffered more casualties in Cambodia
than it did in Vietnam in large part
because Cambodia was even less
structured because the war was even more
chaotic than it was in Vietnam and of
course what Sydney is most widely known
for was staying on after the Khmer Rouge
to vote at least for a matter of some
weeks till till he was expelled one of
the longest or no the longest piece and
here is from is it Michael her hair hair
pronounced Michael hair here he is at
tonsil Nhut Air Base in South Vietnam he
wrote a book called dispatches and why
would you guess that this group that put
this book together I know neither one of
you did would include 200 pages of this
basically devoted to his book it is a
great piece of literature too and it's
it's a quite a it's an entirely new way
of writing about anything really it's
you it's a it's a real original and I
think they they put it in not only
because he gets so deeply into the
experience of of GIS but because it is
it is a wild piece of prose I mean it is
really remarkable agree I think of here
if you surveyed the reporters whose
workers and these volumes and ask them
what is the best book written on Vietnam
an awful lot of them would say
dispatches if you might say or just what
one of war just surly books you know
obviously on the more scholarly level
Bob Chaplin's books but but Mike Mike
cares book hit an awful lot of the notes
that other people were trying to come up
with in their reportage it's a terrific
book
what what's the legacy of Vietnam in
this country well it's certainly you
could see it's still in the way we
approach a military intervention in
other countries for good or for ill
there is a great reluctance to to send
American troops into harm's way great
reluctance even to send in peacekeeping
forces often it's really it determined
the way that the war with Iraq was
fought mainly by high-tech weapons so
forth I think it's left a permanent sort
of scar and I again maybe for good in
many many cases because it certainly
warned us not to go lightly into into
other people's civil wars and make that
kind of a disaster again when you look
at pictures of Ginsburg burrows and
janai here in that this book from that
this is from the 90th this is 1968
Democratic convention Peter Khan and you
think back about the demonstrations were
held there and other places during the
war what would you say the impact of
that was years later well it was clearly
part of a deep division in the in the
American psyche and social fabric I mean
I remember coming back here on a brief
visit somewhere around that time going
to speak on a college campus actually a
very quiet little campus I think bryn
mawr and it I'd sort of tried to talk
about some of the things we've been
talking about here today I mean about
how the war wasn't being fought right
about how we were causing too many
civilian casualties about how Search and
Destroy missions didn't work and
on but what I didn't do was say America
is an evil force or an imperialist
conquering power in Vietnam at the end
of my little speech a young woman stood
up and said you know that was very
interesting but none of us believe a
single word you said and then someone
else kind of came up and said why aren't
you supporting those groovy little
people in the jungle that was the VC
well they weren't you know they weren't
groovy little people in the jungle but
that is how some people in this country
saw them at the time when you look back
again back to that was the the dates
1959 1960 all the way through 73 and
it's written so often a book I want to
ask you who do you think lied to the
American people back then either by name
or by group oh I think almost everybody
happy I think you know a Johnson on down
jorts we'll start with Kennedy because
as I said before they are political
leadership but simply not face up to to
the serious decisions that they were
making at the time and sort of pretended
it wasn't happening and that led to a
lot of other lying all the way down
through the bureaucracy and the military
yes I mean the politicians lied
particularly in terms of how well the
war was going the military lied to
itself within its own chain of command
which was a sad thing military people
out in the field knew how it was going
but those reports never quite reached
the top but having said all that I'm in
the clearly the the North Vietnamese
lied to and in a way with even bigger
lies if you look back and say what did
they say Vietnam was going to be like
after
the so-called liberation and what did it
turn out to be like they lied to one of
the shortest pieces in these 1,500 pages
and only is i'll show the onsen second
first is this photograph of Lyndon
Johnson and Walter Cronkite and the
piece I'm talking about is often written
about it's right here that didn't even
fill two pages and it's the aftermath of
cat februari 1968 we are mired in
stalemate often cited as having been a
turning point Lyndon Johnson I know the
quotes not in here maybe in her summer I
didn't find it said you know that if
we've lost Walter Cronkite than we've
lost the country do you think that that
piece had an impact that mr. Cronkite
speech that he gave on the who what why
when with who what when why CBS report
for every boy the 27 1968 well it
certainly did I mean first of all I mean
Walter Cronkite was um all of our
fathers right um we couldn't look to
anyone else to be the sort of this sort
of perfect balanced a person that we
needed and he what he was it so when he
said something like that everyone took
it extremely seriously I have to say
that that both the New York Times and
The Washington Post correspondence out
there Ward Justin Johnny Apple had had
written that piece essentially already
before the Tet Offensive both in the
autumn of 67 saying it's a stalemate
essentially and that's what that's what
Cronkite Oh was really saying and I
think that within the administration of
course they'd come to the same
conclusions were there for their own
reasons it wasn't wasn't Cronkite that
changed their minds he wrote Peter con
on that day and he gave him gave this
analysis to the public via CBS to say
that we are closer to victory today is
to believe in the face of the evidence
the optimists who have been wrong in the
past he goes on at the end to say but it
is increasingly clear to this reporter
that the
rational way out then we'll be to
negotiate not as Victor's but as an
honorable people who lived up to their
pledge to defend democracy and did the
best they could this is walter cronkite
good night what impact you think he had
yeah I was they are not here at that
time so hard hard to know but I presume
Walter Cronkite's words cared a lot of
weight at the time you know I I think
though probably that a kind of
collective weight of the journalism
coming out of Vietnam including the
television journalism kind of added up
to having more effect than even one
commentator or anchorman would have
would have had at any particular point
in time did any of you know jack p Smith
out there I believe the son of Howard
casement was it he was in the military
did you know him out that there are
other reporters in here Lena's goz
because he wall street journal that he's
now deceased le was was the Washington
Post correspondent out there in 67 68
great courageous reporter and later on
came to work at the Wall Street Journal
and very tragically died less than two
years ago of cancer but one of the one
of my best friends through most of my
life and I think also one of Frankie's
how much actual death did you see when
you were there I don't know how to
measure how much any were you right
there I mean the middle of al's um no I
I didn't cover sort of large you know
two movements and I didn't I didn't
cover G eyes I was my interest was
always with the Vietnamese with the
Vietnamese government with the civilian
population and so forth and so I would
travel outside of American circles most
of the time or and or insofar as they're
Americans there will be with it with
visors two provinces and and so forth so
really violence was a question of timing
you never knew you know you will you
drive along a road and have no idea
whether it was mined or not no idea
whether you'd run into a battle or not
um but I certainly wasn't seeking him
out I bet you yeah I'd say roughly the
same i'm in in large part because the
wall street journal gave me the luxury
not to have to go and write the the
daily kind of war stories i didn't spend
a lot of time with the big American
troop units and so on so if I went out
with American troops it wasn't to cover
a battle per se it was to get some sense
of what they were thinking and doing on
a kind of normal day similarly with
South Vietnamese units so yes I mean I
did see people shot but not because I
wanted to be where someone was being
shot because what happened to be in the
wrong place at the wrong time and
something happened the mortar landed or
something the story of Mila is in the
book of course but also there's a
60-page part of one of the volumes
devoted to a man named Daniel Lang and
you see a photograph of him here it says
1945 here the piece was in The New
Yorker looks like this an atrocity and
it's aftermath of ever 1966 October 1969
casualties of war did either one of you
remember this piece oh yes but I haven't
read it for a long time well you know I
we can't do it justice in the little
time we have here but it's a story about
how a group of American soldiers took a
young Vietnamese girl raped her and shot
her and killed her it's long and in its
detailed and how one of the members of
the group talk after was all over and I
bring it up to ask the two of you how
often you remember Americans being
involved in these tragedies and why you
think they did I don't think those
things were all that common clearly male
I happened I presume about a lesser
scale there
or some others this kind of incident you
describe but I mean the main suffering
that America caused was much more
mindless random kind of suffering it was
free-fire zones it was Search and
Destroy missions it was someone sitting
in a map declaring a certain part of a
certain province VC territory which then
permitted any amount of firepower being
directed at that portion of the province
and in that proportion of the province
not all the people would have been Viet
Cong or North Vietnamese combatants
there would have been civilians and that
gets it how difficult it is to fight a
fundamentally gorilla type war but the
the suffering we caused there tended to
be much more from thousands of feet up
with the bombs and with the artillery
pieces than it was a small group of
soldiers going off and committing some
some specific act of violence against a
particular civilian let's say it
happened but I don't think that was in
any way typical of the American GI and
Vietnam appears absolutely right and
it's unfortunately they I think the sort
of press appetite for these for these
kinds of stories was so great that they
actually neglected this other and far
more destructive behavior I mean I
remember Kevin Buckley who has a piece
in there discovered that the 9th
division when it was went in the went
down to the Delta for a period in 69
caused horrendous of civilian casualties
I mean no American division had been in
the Delta before because so thickly
populated and they just went about you
know bombing and artillery so so forth
and Kevin could hardly get this piece
published because it wasn't me lie to
you know and yet it was far more
destructive
of the other than the other thing one
does have to keep remembering is that
when it came to specific acts of
violence that was a tactic that the
Vietcong of the North Vietnamese did use
I mean they did assassinate village
leaders and you know that kind of thing
went on on both sides we to some extent
then copied them with things like the
Phoenix program and the pru units so
there was another level of quite
targeted very nasty violence on both
sides either one of you know this man
Bernard fall Gaiden februari 21st 1967
and one of the first to write about the
of course you wrote about DN bien phu in
the French did you know it i bet him any
impact that he had me one of the things
you Robert McNamara told us in his book
is that we did he didn't have experts
didn't Lyndon Johnson said they didn't
have enough experts on the Asian part of
the world either one of you agree with
that they didn't have enough but but
they had some and certainly Bernhard
Falls books would have would have told
him something I mean my belief is that
that their estimates were pretty good I
mean actually much better sir tinley
much better than we thought they were if
so and if they wanted more expertise
they could have gotten I just didn't
want to hear that they didn't want to
hear no this can't be one didn't get and
they only had a little bit of time of
your reaction to the legacy of Vietnam
earlier I think it clearly has left a
scar on America a particularly asst in
the area of trust of our institutions
and for a period of time it had a quite
devastating effect on morale in the US
military I think the morale newest
military has turned around and is very
strong these days again and i think the
scars the other scars of vietnam by and
large are healing and I think to some
extent Ronald Reagan deserves some of
the credit for that
these are the two volumes as we said
earlier the 1500 pages between the two
of them they sell for thirty-five
dollars each put out by the library of
america called reporting vietnam there
are some 113 pieces in here some 80
different writers 64 pages of
photographs and our guests to talk about
them are people that have our two guests
here have articles in them Peter Khan
and Frances Fitzgerald and thank you
very much for out of time thank you
thank you